-This is easy.
-The password is "shoplifter."
-Can I say a name?
-Yeah, one word though.
-Winona.
[ Laughter ]
-Shoplifter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?! Oh, my gosh.
-Easy!
-Oh, my God.
-Stacey, you go.
-We're going to start with
Melissa on this one.
-Okay, wait, which way --
-The password is "marijuana."
[ Laughter ]
-Smoke.
-Pot.
-No.
-Like.
[ Laughter ]
-Jagger.
-Synonym.
-Fire.
No!
-Smoke.
-Do I even need to
give you a clue?
-I don't know, you might as
well, but I think I got it.
-Bong.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Weed?
-Oh!
-Marijuana!
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nobody calls it that anymore!
I haven't even heard the word
"marijuana" in years.
-That's why they give it to me.
-The password is "booty."
[ Laughter ]
-I can't see it.
-Call.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Booty?
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-No way!
No, no, no, no way!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Are you kidding me?
-Wow!
-I swear.
-That is gonna -- That's going
in the Hall of Shame.
-What was yours gonna be?
-Pirates.
-Oh, see, yeah, see?
Get your mind out of the gutter.
-Jimmy and Steve.
-Oh!
-The password is "soprano."
-Steve, you're gonna
start us off.
-Okay.
-[ New Jersey accent ] Tony.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Soprano?
-What?! Come on!
-I knew that.
-You knew that?
-Oh.
-Come on.
-Apparently this barn is
on fire.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Booty call!
-No one says that.
-The password is "blush."
-Reese, you're gonna do
this one.
-Mm. Hmm, hmm.
-She's cheating already.
-Makeup.
-Is that hyphenated?
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's one word.
-Okay.
-What's the word?
-Makeup.
-Yeah.
-Revlon.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh. That's kind of a diss.
[ Audience booing ]
-Say "Cover Girl."
Say "Cover Girl."
-Cover Girl!
[ Laughter ]
-Good cover-up.
Good cover-up, buddy.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Good cover-up.
-As is all of Cover Girl makeup.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Yes.
-Rouge.
[ Laughter ]
-Makeup, rouge.
Ellen DeGeneres?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-You pointed at you.
I thought --
-No, no.
-Do I get another chance?
-Yep.
-Okay, okay.
-It's one word too.
-I'm ready. I'm ready.
Cheeks.
[ Laughter ]
-Blush.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-You're yelling at me. Alright!
-Where are we?
-Alright.
-Is this the last one?
-This is the last one.
This is the last one.
This is worth 1,000 points.
[ Laughter ]
Whoever wins this one
wins the game.
That's how close we are.
Jimmy and Steve.
-I wasn't gonna say blush.
-The password is "joint."
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, you are going to start
the game whenever you're ready.
Are you ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-Are you sure you're ready?
-Yes.
-Then start in 3, 2...
[ Laughter ]
-Weed.
-Pot.
[ Laughter ]
-No. No.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a theme.
-Spliff.
[ Laughter ]
-Um...
-Oh!
-Uh...
Snoop?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know!
-Two points.
-We're going to get this.
-Oh, I know you're gonna get it.
-Rolled.
-Joint.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-The password is "umbrella."
-Here, why don't you --
Start us off.
-It's one word, one word.
-One word. One word.
-Michelle, we got this.
Come on. Let's get in the zone.
AutoZone.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-Parasol.
-Umbrella.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Boom!
-What?!
-Bang!
-Unbelievable.
-Six points!
Oh, my gosh.
-That's fantastic.
-Kyle.
-I knocked the table over.
Alright.
-Jimmy.
-Oh, yeah. Thank you.
-The password is "parrot."
-Kyle, you're up first.
One word.
One word, Kyle, to Tariq.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Squawks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Judges?
-He said "kwaw," K-W-A-W.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Can I repeat it?
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Squawks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Chicken.
-Oh!
-Jimmy.
-Close.
-Polly.
-Parrot.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bang!
-You're great.
-Oh, my gosh!
-He helped that one.
That was good, man.
That was good.
-Tariq and Michelle.
-The password is "snooze."
-Tariq, why don't you
start us off?
-Come on, Tariq, don't lose this
for your team.
[ Laughter ]
-No pressure.
-Nap.
[ Laughter ]
-Sleep.
-Oh!
-Michelle.
[ Laughter ]
She seems pretty confident.
-Um...
-Nap. Sleep. It's in that area.
I get it.
-Uh-huh.
-Could be "doze."
But it's not, so you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Doze.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Doze.
-Okay.
No.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, gosh, I just gave
my own clue. Okay.
Sleep. Nap. Doze.
Gosh, I didn't mean to say that,
sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Sleep. Nap. Doze.
Narcoleptic?
[ Laughter ]
-Almost. Narcoleptic.
Tariq, back to you
for four points.
Four sweet ones.
-I'm getting into it.
-Clock.
-What?
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Don't overthink this.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I got it!
-Too late.
-I got it! Yes, I do!
-Not yet. Not yet.
Cool your jets.
-What's your Fitbit
number up to right now?
[ Laughter ]
-Just between the commercial,
45,000.
-Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
-I do not know.
No.
-We're gonna take home the win.
We're gonna take home the win.
-Oh, God.
-We're gonna take home the win.
You can say any one word
you want. I got it.
[ Laughter ]
No. Rest. Rest.
-No.
-Just say any word. I got it.
-Button.
-Snooze!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Alright.
-Button. That was good.
-That was good.
-Final one.
-Clock was good.
-That was good.
-Final clue.
-Alright, final one, here we go.
-The password is "sour."
-Jimmy, why don't you
start us off?
-Okay.
-Sweet.
[ Laughter ]
-Sour?
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are the best.
-Oh, my gosh!
-I've never seen this.
We crushed!
We are the champions!